this is crazy because everyone's coming
after me with ideas what should we do
and it's hard to you know he has
everything he has everything Gwen
Stefani brainstorming gift ideas for
hubby Blake Shelton's exit from The
Voice I think his favorite thing would
be a bag of corn like that would be
honestly like he would be so thrilled
um or fertilizer or something like that
as Blake gears up for his final round of
the competition series two newcomers are
joining for season 23. Chance the Rapper
and Niall Horan I'm excited for for both
of them to be on the voice it's just
such an incredibly inspiring show to be
on if you are an artist because not only
you're around so much music and you're
like thinking of what song could work
for this voice and um you're also just
like you look back at your own Journey
you know what I'm saying and you just
you go wow like I know all this now like
I can share this and I think playing
that role has just been so inspiring for
me since I've been on the show now six
seasons
um never thought I would do something
like this but honestly feel like it's
one of the most fun things I've ever
done which I just never saw coming you
know what I mean
um but I think they're gonna really like
it they're gonna be really inspired in a
way like that they didn't know
um and just I would just say have fun be
in the moment because nothing lasts
forever guys but for now the coaches are
taking the stage for their first live
shows of Season 22 and Gwen's revealing
why she thinks her team is full of
potential winners well I mean
it's hard to say because every show is
its own thing you never know what's
going to happen that's what's so
incredibly mysterious about the voice I
mean you just never know who's gonna
rise right or who's gonna all sudden be
like Oh I thought they were better you
know what I mean so but I do have
um two people on my team that are
blowing my mind that I kind of I don't
like to say oh I think I have the winner
because who knows you know what I mean
but I think they're both different one
is uh for me and I'm not saying names
obviously but um one of them has just
this extraordinary voice it's one of
those things where it's like there's
just something about it just so skilled
it's insane but also there's so much
heart behind that but I would say that
the other person is um incredibly
creative and so it's hard because you
don't know like everybody has different
things that are they're good at you know
what I'm saying some people just have
like on my team I have someone that's
just really good at stage presence and
you just kind of Can't Keep Your Eye Off
them and then
um another one that's just like in a
really skilled singer and then another
one that's like just super creative and
talented and unique so it's like I don't
know like I just know that I have an
incredible team this season I always do
but I feel like there's something really
different about this season overall I
just feel like it's been a really
relaxed season I haven't planned
anything I just kind of been in the
moment as much as possible when I've
been pressing my button I was like no
pressure I was definitely pressing when
Blake would press because I like to mess
with him but I also like to follow his
taste everybody knows that they call me
out on it it's fine you're right
wouldn't you but yeah it's been a good
one
foreign